[Music]
this was being back in March in
Kazakhstan a Soyuz rocket carrying two
American astronauts and a Russian
cosmonaut blasted off for the six-hour
flight to the International Space
Station today 289 days later just one of
them remains in space and this morning
she is setting a space milestone
christina cook now holds the record for
the longest single space flight by a
woman but her Space Odyssey is about
much more than just the duration of her
time away from Earth christina cook was
greeted with hugs when she arrived at
the International Space Station
eight-and-a-half months ago realizing a
dream she'd had since childhood the 40
year old engineer was originally
supposed to spend six months in space
but in April her stay was extended to
last nearly a year and today she breaks
the record held by retired astronaut
Peggy Whitson for the longest single
trip in space by a woman it's a huge
honor Peggy is a heroine of mine who's
also been kind enough to mentor me
through the years and so it's a reminder
to give back into mentor when I get back
part of kooks mission is to study the
effects of long-term space travel on the
human body I also like to think of it as
it's not so many so much how many days
you're up here but what you do with each
of those days so that reminds me to
bring my best to every single day I
think it's wonderful for science
it helps us push the boundaries of what
we know about what long-duration space
flight can do to the human body and
that's important for our future
exploration deeper into going to Mars
and also returning to the moon and going
there to stay since her mission began
Cook has completed four spacewalks
including one that was history-making in
its own right all right beneath your
feet so don't go in October she and
fellow astronaut Jessica Muir conducted
the first all-female spacewalk snapping
selfies as they swapped out faulty
batteries on the International Space
Station and following it up with a phone
call from President Trump I just want to
congratulate you what you do is
incredible it's so you're very brave
people I don't think I want to do it I
must tell you that Cook discussed that
milestone with us yesterday
on CBS this morning why do you think
we're seeing these milestones now for
women in space
you know I think it's a wonderful time
for human space play because I think we
finally recognized that it's not worth
going unless we go together that it's
important to not turn away any
innovative idea that everyone has a role
and everyone has a place at the table as
we move forward if we're gonna go for
all humanity and to support humanity's
love for exploration then we have to do
it with all humanity and I think we're
seeing that as our plans unfold for
going back to the moon seeing the first
woman walk on the moon in 2024 and just
recognizing that we have to go together
if we're gonna go and we're gonna do it
right
well she's not on earth Cook has kept
her eye on Home Sharing photos of our
planet with her 145 thousand Twitter
followers most recently a picture of
Mount Everest I would say the most
awe-inspiring thing that I've ever seen
is the Northern Lights or Southern
Lights or Aurora's we call them from
above on a planetary scale I've had the
opportunity working in Antarctica and
the Arctic to see them from below and
the beautiful shimmering lights along
the sky and taking over the whole sky
but to look down on the earth and see
the entire shape of the Aurora's you
know as they form near the poles was
truly an amazing sight and just
literally took my breath away being away
for so long has required sacrifice
including spending holidays away from
family while suspended in zero gravity
still Cook says she hopes her record
doesn't last long
my number-one hope for this milestone is
that the record has exceeded again as
soon as possible because that means that
we're continuing to push the boundaries
and in the end it should be three
hundred and twenty eight days February 6
2020 is when she's set to come back what
I think is so neat is she had talked to
us yesterday about how you know she
wanted to do this as a young girl but
her class is the first that was an even
split of men and women so all the young
girls now out there that maybe look out
there and can dream about doing this -
and I know space blocks they've gotten
more routine if they can ever be routine
but I never get tired of looking at that
it's just so fascinating and the view is
not bad
you